[Musique]
rosalia répète en français après mois
après mois je suis passé chez sosh je
suis passé chez ca
mais les bordelais
[Musique]
[Rires]
tu peux avoir une photo que tu peux
avoir une photo ac s'est pas encore fini
le spectre
ma chérie je vais pas de baisser pour
des raisons que tu connais quelques
remarques sur scène c'est vrai voilà
macrophytes sans
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
merci
qu'est ce qu'un
élu et non
à taper revint
[Rires]
[Musique]
toi aussi tu as pété
même si je vais en péter c'est pour ça
j'ai ouvert
non je vais en péter c'est tout
[Musique]
je
salue bien de penser
[Musique]
il paraît que c'est impossible d'être
triste et heureux à la fois que tu en
penses bah c'est faux de tous tes potes
c'est toi qui a la plus grosse